So I wanna start by offering you a free,
no-tech life hack
and all it requires of you is this
that you change your
posture for two minutes.
Do you remember the power pose craze
from about a decade ago?
In the second most popular TED Talk ever,
psychologist Amy Cuddy told
over 60 million viewers
that they can change their life outcomes
by simply changing their body language.
Tiny tweaks can lead to big changes.
This is two minutes, two minutes,
two minutes, two minutes.
Cuddy sparked a movement supposedly rooted
in science around the idea
that changing your posture
can change everything around you.
By striking power poses
in tough situations,
women could even gain equality
in corporate board rooms.
The problem is none of it was true,
says science writer Jesse Singal
even according to Cuddy's own research.
One of Cuddy's two co-authors,
a woman named Dana Carney
who's at UC Berkeley.
She posted a thing to her
faculty website saying,
I think we made some methodological
errors in this study.
I think the effect is totally false.
So even one of the people
who discovered power posing
has come out and said,
there's nothing there.
Singal is the author of, 'The Quick Fix
"Why Fad Psychology Can't
Cure Our Social Ills'
Which looks at how,
academics and policy makers
routinely oversell their pet projects
as the one easy way to address
some major social problem.
The goal of this book
is to explain to people
why we keep falling for the
ideas that psychologists tell us
about the ways they
gonna help fix society.
And these ideas have
had a really good time
in the 21st century.
They've gone viral.
TED-Talks culture is doing quite well.
Over and over and over,
I've noticed that these ideas
will burst onto the scene,
they'll offer some incredible
new way to fight racism
or to improve education
or to improve gender
equity in the workplace.
There's a rush of attention.
Often a rush of research dollars.
Everyone gets really into them.
There's the NPR and New
York Times coverage.
And then a few years later,
more research comes out.
We realized the idea
was barely true if that,
and it ends up having wasted a lot of time
Singal Points to other fad ideas
that have had long lasting impacts,
the self-esteem movement
which sought to boost academic achievement
by making students feel
good about themselves,
regardless of performance
dominated public school curriculum
starting in the 1980s.
This idea was championed by a
powerful California legislator
who believes that praising
kids and even criminals
would help them to overcome obstacles.
The problem is the claim
that improving self-esteem
can fix all these
negative societal outcomes
which there was never
really any evidence for it.
There's not a harm to like,
making people feel like
they're loved to have worth.
The harm is like partly opportunity costs.
I think with a lot of these ideas
people really like get a
little bit fixated on them
at the expense of other
more important things.
So if you really think
criminals are committing crimes
as a result of low self-esteem,
that might distract you from actual things
that contribute to high crime rates.
Singal says, one of the most influential
and pernicious quick fixes
has to do with implicit bias
especially with regard to racism.
He points to the Implicit
Association Test or IAT ,
a free online quiz that supposedly shows
how takers are unconsciously biased
with regard to overweight
people, gays women,
and especially blacks
and other minorities.
The test received glowing media attention
from the likes of Malcolm
Gladwell and Nicholas Kristof.
It routinely used
in all sorts of diversity
training programs
and educational settings from
K through 12 through college,
yet there's at least two major problems
with the IAT says Singal.
You got very different tasks on the IAT
in a short, period if you
retake it, that's one problem.
The other problem is validity,
which is basically proof
that the test is measuring
something out in the real world.
So the claim for a long time was that
you get a high score
on the Black white IAT
that predicts you're going to
discriminate against people.
It doesn't seem to really,
except in the tiniest way.
I mean, it's statistically significant
but it's almost certainly not
relevant to the real world.
The best estimate we have is that
your IAT score, IAT score
explained about 1% of the variance
in people's discriminatory
behavior in lab settings
which is just a fancy way of saying that
it predicts very well.
One of the goals of 'The Quick Fix'
is to make people more
aware of our willingness
to believe that, all our
problems can be cured easily
by focusing on one thing.
Yeah I think humans just
by dint of our brains
we're always can be susceptible to
less than rigorous mana causal accounts.
So like power posing was like,
Oh, we just got to make
women feel more powerful.
They never bothered to prove that
that's really, what's
driving these discrepancies.
I think these ideas like take these big,
complicated, tangled problems
and just zoom in on a little bit of it
and it would be nice
if addressing that bit
could address a whole thing
but there's often not a lot of evidence.
That's the case.